well and you've got a lot of friends in
the business so you get to tour with
your friends and that do has there been
any um because you tour with other
Comics jealousy or you know do you
compete with friends no we're all we all
get it but you know but when you see
somebody get a TV show do you ever sit
back and go I should
be only uh you know I did for a little
bit and then I realized that that was
that seeing a shrink uh that was in
insane you know that I'm we're not in
the same Lane they got it that's great
I'm going to get I'm going to get what
I'm going to get they're going to get
what they're going to get also I didn't
you know sometimes too I go you you
might have gotten it if you moved to LA
or you know you never wanted to move
here no I wasn't good here I'm like
really in trouble here I why uh I always
felt there was something weird here that
I mean that there yeah you well you for
starters okay and there's a list no but
I would be I would be driving around La
and this is the kind of thing and not
like massively but just a sense of what
I feel about La that I could be driving
and and above the mountains a giant
dinosaur could appear and I could turn
to my friend and go see I told you
that's what's a m see what's up there
something that's coming our way and I
just I felt like something weird could
happen here at any moment and I wouldn't
be shocked at all I can tell you I was
uh born and raised here never have I
ever seen a dinosaur come over the
mountain ever and you don't wait wait
wait and you don't think that in man
were you Manhattan yeah yeah you don't
think in New York isn't that Godzilla
wasn't that the every movie that's ever
happened with climbing the uh the Empire
State Building there's more of a chance
of that happening there Jurassic Park
literally didn't they go into Manhattan
the
dinosaurs in Jurassic Park four it took
them long enough something like that but
they never came to La no they didn't but
here's the here's the here's the the
reason I don't and the reason you don't
uhuh I don't in New York because I was
from there my family was from there
aren't you from Maryland yeah but but I
spent my family was from there so I
spent a ton of time in New York so it
and then I wasn't going to move to New
York and when I finally moved there I
went H this is really where I belong and
it's if I want to do theater this is
where you do it and I never felt I felt
nothing but comfortable there you know
that makes sense the dinosaur story
takes it to another level yes no the
dinosaur thing is just my I said it's
don't take it seriously but you were
born and raised here there's a
difference too between people born and
raised here than those of us who come
out in out here hello yeah I'm Canadian
I know and what brought you here
dinosaurs
he